cyberpunk 2077 is buggy
notoriously buggy so much so that it was
pulled from the playstation store just
one week after its release and suspended
until cd projekt red could get the game
in a better working condition
and even though i was as jazzed to play
cyberpunk as anyone else
life hit and i ended up missing the game
so
seven months later and after a barrage
of less than stellar reviews
as well as a number of critical patches
i'm finally playing the game for the
first time
as a huge fan of deus ex human
revolution and deus ex mankind divided
which both covered cybernetic
enhancements and had similar rpg
shooter formulas i still figured
cyberpunk 2077 couldn't be
all that bad because to me
cyberpunk 2077 always just looked like a
sequel to deus ex
the game was recently patched to the
point where it was finally once again
available for purchase on the
playstation store and with that epic
milestone i was able to convince my
bosses at gamespot to let me play the
game for the first time
despite our already extensive coverage
so i could see what it was like to play
a game that is now
at least workable enough to be released
and was definitely
definitely not just an excuse to play a
game i've been wanting to play for work
definitely my quest to play cyberpunk
2077 began with buying it on a physical
medium
you see i'm one of those relics of an
old age who prefer physical copies of
games so i can feel like i own them
as you can see i've wasted a huge amount
of money on games you can buy at a
fraction of the price
so i drove over to my local best buy
only to find out they didn't carry the
game
less than a year later that took me 30
minutes out to another best buy where
they just happened to have a copy of the
game
stashed away in the back and it was only
30 bucks
it even came with this map that i'll
probably never look at
and these sweet postcards that i can't
wait to send to my family
to reconfirm i'm a giant nerf so after
waiting
40 minutes for the game to download onto
my ps5 i excitedly started to get
oh a 45.2 gigabyte file
great great great and thus i stopped my
first recording and decided to go to the
park to work out while i waited
[Music]
and i'm back lucky me cyberpunk 2077 was
up and ready to be played
i chose normal difficulty because i just
assumed that's how the developers want
you to play the game
as a youtuber i felt that no bad life
was right for me because i've also moved
a few points in my life
and while i thought this hairstyle might
be the most accurate to me
no you may not see the back of my head
this is a fantasy world so i chose a
slightly different haircut
as a side note this is a future where
you can completely chrome out your body
and implants
so how have they still not solved male
pattern baldness
after that i was in the extremely
immersive world of cyberpunk 2077
or so was advertised but one of the
first things i ran into
were these people playing cards and
having a barbecue most of whom i
couldn't talk to when i tried and maybe
that was a good thing
i have no reason to live with vo like
that
i get it honey you gotta tell me how you
got to be
you uh excuse me are you talking to me
with a soda in your mouth
ah you want to have a good time but as a
fan of shenmue i
guess i can't really complain do you
have a minute
sorry kid we're busy learn check with
someone else
do you know anyone who might know this
charlie guy nah
can't think of anyone so i guess that
was the first thing i noticed
how lifeless the npcs felt and roughly
an hour in
it happened my first glitch jackie
walking right through an elevator
it wasn't a very big one but after
hearing so much about the game's bugs
i was ready for a symphony of game
breaking glitches
don't get me wrong don't got nothing
against the padre or wakako but
i think part of the reason i was excited
for these bugs was because initially i
was a little
underwhelmed and while i'll mention my
overall experience later
let's talk about those glitches because
let's be honest
that's probably why you're watching and
don't you worry
i still found plenty like early on when
evelyn parker had a purse stuck inside
of her hand
so anytime she talked this random purse
would move around
oh oh never mind it just went flying
wait it's attached to her hand again
there were plenty of minor glitches
like times when i'd be talking to
someone and then they suddenly glitched
to a slightly different location
people randomly appearing chairs
randomly flying everywhere
this suitcase which decided to just flow
to midair because it had nowhere needed
to be i guess
sneaking into a corner that i got stuck
inside of
walking behind a crate and suddenly
clipping through it and being able to
see
all of the world and cars flying around
my arm not fully loading
i scared this enemy so badly that they
just fell over and died
there was the time i had to carry taki
kimochi's body to the fixer and the
mission didn't seem to end
so i had to improvise and throw taki
kenmochi's body on top of a car
while trying out some new outfits there
were times when they would just load
as uh me being naked
no shirt despite wearing a shirt no
jacket
no shoes and of course
no pants wait why don't i have a penis
when did this happen at one point i
messed up a stealth section where i took
out a guard and then got spotted
i reloaded my save and suddenly there
was no guard in the spot he'd been in
before
he was magically missing in taking out
another guard
who somehow didn't notice jackie walk
right in front of him
the original guard had magically
reappeared
then there were the more annoying ones
for example when i dropped the foot down
onto a ledge
and immediately died
[Music]
i was so confused that i tried it again
and was completely fine the second time
around in another instance i finished
the mission and was ready to leave when
i discovered i had to talk to jackie
again
however jackie had gotten himself
trapped inside of a location
i could no longer enter hey stop pushing
me
i need to talk to jackie the only way i
could resolve this one was by reloading
an earlier save
in this particular instance i was trying
to sneak take down one of the game's
cyber psychos
after accidentally alerting him i left
his range came back
and realized that despite sneaking
behind him i couldn't kill him
in fact i stood up and walked in front
of him without alerting him
i could even talk to him sup
yeah he didn't even mind when i shot him
a couple times
what a swell guy ironically in another
mission where i was trying to take down
a cyber psycho a netrunner was trying to
hack me
and the overheat hack just got stuck
at 85 percent no matter where i walked
or what i did and the creme de la creme
i did have multiple instances where the
game completely glitched out and booted
me out of the game
and bear in mind i'm playing on a ps5
with the most recent updates
but i'd rather end this with my absolute
favorite glitches that happened
because honestly most of these just
cracked me up rather than really
bothering me
for example at one point i decided to
stealth take down an enemy sitting on a
couch
after knocking him out the enemy stood
right back up
walked his couch
and then immediately died when he sat
back down that must have been one
hell of a brain dance he was watching
after reading that people were having
trouble vaulting in the windows
i decided to reload an older save and
try this myself in the ghost town
mission
after realizing the window did not want
to shatter
despite shooting it and trying to punch
it i jumped in and ended up getting
vaulted
100 meters backwards and needed to
sprint back to where i'd been and
speaking of ghost town
when i tried to romance pan am during
the mission
v maybe we rent just one room maybe
calls for a little celebration
sure we can celebrate
but not today i'm beat it turns out all
i had to do to be inside of her
was reload one of my earlier auto saves
where i was
literally inside of her the game had
loaded me
into her driver's seat while she was
driving the car
and may i just say pan am you have very
exquisite eyeballs but i saved my
favorite one for last
in a later side mission i tried to
stealth take down an enemy
only for this to happen
i was worried at first i'd get spotted
for you know constantly knocking him
out like this but fortunately none of
the enemies seemed to notice or
mind that was also when i realized that
every time i killed him
he dropped another gun so when i finally
found a dumpster to drop him off in
i was rewarded with this massive stash
of shotguns
so of course i looted every single one
of them
but the game didn't like that i mean it
worked and i disassembled most of them
as they were pretty much worthless to me
other than for parts
but for the next around 10 to 20 minutes
the game was still trying to give me
pop-up notifications that i picked up a
shotgun
as it had back catalogued the nearly 100
shotguns i'd picked up
so those were just some of the glitches
i've encountered so far
and honestly most of them are just goofy
and aren't truly game breaking
as the game constantly auto saves and i
also do manual saves
any of the truly annoying glitches which
were honestly extremely infrequent
i could just load up an older save so
far i've played maybe around
30 hours of the game so bear in mind
everything i just showed you wasn't all
happening at once
i probably have around one of these
glitches an hour with them
usually being the more minor ones so it
looks a lot worse than when i was
actually playing
yes it was annoying but it didn't kill
the game for me
in fact even though i didn't get to
finish playing cyberpunk for this video
i'm still playing for fun because
honestly i really enjoy it
while i was initially underwhelmed by
the story and at the beginning i
couldn't help but compare cyberpunk to
deus
ex human revolution which immediately
had an intriguing story
i ended up getting super into cyberpunk
and its world
on top of that the more side quests i
played the more i got hooked
it got to the point where i continued to
put off any and all of the main quests
which i actually was super interested in
just because i enjoyed playing the side
quest so much
to be honest i didn't really feel like
the massive open world particularly
enhanced the game
but i also didn't mind it to me it
suffered from the same issues many games
of this size do which is that a lot of
it feels empty
in spite of the bazillion missions and
side quests you can take on
but despite some of these gripes i
honestly came away not really
identifying with the massive backlash
the game received
i understand it didn't live up to the
hype for many but at the same time
it's still a fun game that completely
absorbed me into its world
i wasn't expecting the greatest game of
all time
but rather a fun game comparable to deus
ex
and that's pretty much what i got but
maybe that was also because i was
playing a patched version of the game on
a ps5
and i would have walked away with a
completely different experience seven
months ago
especially since i completely missed the
insane hype train for the game
and my expectations have definitely been
tampered since then
so at the end of the day is the game
still buggy seven months later
yes and i'm playing on a ps5 so i have
no idea how bad the ps4 version might be
but for 30 bucks i really like it and
i'm happy i had the chance to play it
crazy bugs and all
[Music]
you